大家好 今天我将继续介绍隐私保护机器学习
今天我们要讲述的课题是联邦学习
我叫李亚亮
是来自阿里巴巴达摩愿法尔迪勒斯科夫团队的
在今天的课程中
我们主要会针对联邦学习
这一个课题讲述三个部分
第一个部分是对联邦学习的一个概述
给大家讲述一些联邦学习的设定以及基本的概念
在第二个部分
我们将基于联邦学习平台Fidiotescope
给大家讲述一些动手实践
然后在第三个部分
我们将针对一些比较热门的研究方向进行一些具体的介绍
包括图联邦学习
FGL
个性化联邦学习
PFL
联邦学习中的自动调餐
Fide HPO
以及联邦学习中的攻击
FL Attack
那我们就先来看一看联邦学习
一些概念的概述
在我们日常生活中
我们用到某些app或者一些应用服务的时候
我们作为用户
很可能会将自己的一些
本地的私有数据
如定位数据
图片
语音
或者有时候甚至一些视频数据
然后传到
使用app的服务器段
在另外一些
场景中
然后出于一些研究
或者说是商业的目的
多个组织或者机构之间
比如说银行与银行之间
或者医院与医院之间
大家会通过共享一些用户的数据
来进行一些共建
那么在这两种
比较典型的场景中
我们作为用户都会有这样一个很严重的考虑
就是说
我的私人数据在被共享时
是否安全呢
然后随着这几年
公众对于隐私保护的意识越来越强
然后以及有越来越多的国家与地区
都出台了相关的法律法规
譬如说我们国家的个人信息保护法
以及欧洲的基地批押
所有的这些法律法规
都促使
隐私保护机器学习这一课题的研究与实践
联邦学习
作为
解决
隐私顾虑的一种新的学习范氏
他希望能够在不泄漏用户隐私数据的情况下
给予多个分散的数据员
完成协同训练
然后在联邦学习中
我们希望说参议方之间传递的是一些抽象的学道的知识
而不是原始的私有数据
那通过这样一个
想法
然后用户的原始隐私数据
能够得到一些保护
最开始
讲到的两种比较典型的场景
也对应了联邦学习中两个非常重要的一个设定
第一个叫cross-device联邦学习
也叫跨设备的联邦学习
在这一个设定中
参与方是大量的中端设备
如手机
LT设备等等
在这种场景下
参与到联邦学习中的
参与方的数目是非常大的
从几百个
甚至到几万
甚至更大的数目
然后这些中端设备
都拥有自己的本地数据
以及计算资源
大家希望通过协同训练的一个方式
然后能得到一个全局模型
再另外一个典型的场景是cross-sello联邦学习
也叫跨机构的联邦学习
在这样一个设定下
参与的是多个组织或者机构
但是相比于前面cross-device这样一个场景
cross-sello中
参与方的数目往往不会很多
大概只是若干个
甚至很多时候是两个或者三个参与方
大家通过一种联合学习的方式
进行一个协作建模
我们再开始谈到
联邦学习的一个最大的初衷
是为了给用户的数据提供隐私保护
我们也说到了
联邦学习可以提供一定程度的保护
因为在联邦学习中
不同的参与方之间传递的
是一些抽象的知识
而不是原始的数据
但是这样一个保护
可能依然在很多场景中是不足够的
那么为了进一步满足不同任务
或者说不同场景下的隐私保护需求
联邦学习做一种比较新的学习方式
它可以很好的
和其他的隐私保护技术进行一个协同
譬如说包括X分隐私DP
同态加密HE
以及多方安全计算MPC
那接下来
我们就对这三种技术进行一个简单的介绍与讨论
X分隐私也叫Diffrensional Privacy
它的一个核心想法是说
在本地的信息或者说数据
在被共享以及分享前
我们注入一些噪声来对它进行扰动
譬如说在这个例子中
不同的中端数据
在将本地数据发给云端的时候
我们可以在数据中注入一些噪声
以来保护自己的数据中的隐私
那么注入噪声也就意味着
会对学到的模型的性能
起到一定的负面作用
那么隐私保护机器学习中
使用X分隐私的时候
一个最重要的科题
就是如何去考量隐私保护强度
以及学到的模型性能之间的一个平衡
然后当然这里也设计到
另外一个比较重要的科题
就是说在给定一定的隐私预算
也就是ParciBudget的情况下
如何合理的去分配
然后第二个可以和联邦学习进行协同的
技术叫同态加密
它和一般的加密技术
最大的区别就在于同态
那什么叫同态呢
譬如说我们考虑这个例子加法同态
然后我们将原始的数据A和B
然后分别加密
然后将密文进行一个加法
这样的结果等同于
我们先在明文上进行加法
然后再将明文的结果进行一个加密
然后当然还有惩法同态
有了加法同态以及惩法同态之后
那么参与方就可以直接在加密之后的数据上
进行一个计算与协作
而不需要在原始的数据上
当然同态加密的一个问题
就是说它的计算量会比较大
然后第三个可以于联邦学习进行协作的
隐私保护技术叫多方安全计算MPC
在这里我们先简单介绍一下
MPC中的秘密分享
譬如说我们先考虑我们现在有
三个客户端123
然后我们要对他们的一条隐私数据
进行一个求取平均值这样一个操作
那么如何做到可以既保证结果的准确性
同时又保护每个参与方的隐私呢
然后首先每个客户端将自己的数据进行
一个分片split
然后将不同的segment
也就是不同的分片
然后发送到其他客户端
那么这样的话
从每个客户端的角度来说
大家用的信息都是一些碎片
并不足以能够完整的去推测出
每个客户端的原始数据
然后将这些碎片每个客户端聚合之后
发给服务端
服务端在这些收到的
这些碎片化信息之上
然后算取譬如说平均值
那么这个结果可以大家可以看到
它其实等同于我们在原始的数据上
直接算取平均值
但是通过秘密分享这一策略
我们既保证了结果的准确性
同时也保证
不管是客户端还是服务端
它都没有足够的知识
去推测出每个客户端原始的数据是什么
那么在这种情况下
通过多方安全计算
我们就可以做到
给每个客户端提供一些更多的隐私保护
在第一个部分中
我们对联邦学习的一些基本概念
以及联邦学习
如何与其他的隐私保护技术进行一个协同
然后进行了介绍
那么在第二部分中
我们通过动手实践
来加深大家对联邦学习的理解
然后在这一部分的动手实践
我们将基于Fidgeter Scope
这个联邦学习平台来进行讲解
那么事实上联邦学习平台发展至今
已经有非常多优秀的平台
这其中包括Google的TensorFlow Federated
然后以及包括在国内影响力
比较大的微众银行的FIT
以及包括螞蟻集团的英语
然后我们在接下来
我们会基于我们阿里巴巴达摩院
开发的Fidgeter Scope这个平台
来进行一些实战的讲解
那么相比于其他的联邦学习平台
Fidgeter Scope有什么特点呢
然后简单来说最重要的一个特点
就是说Fidgeter Scope
它采用了事件驱动的这样一个
编程范式来进行设计
然后这样可以兼顾意用性以及灵活性
然后通过Event Driven这样一个Architecture
Fidgeter Scope它可以为每一个联邦的参与者
都提供一个独立的编程视角
然后这样一个好处
将会在个性化联邦学习PFL
以及比较复杂的图联邦学习FGL
以及包括联邦学习的攻击FL Attack中
都得到更好的体现
我们后续大家可以看到
Event Driven这样一个编程范式的好处
然后这样一个设计
然后也非常遍于研究人员进行
联邦学习算法的研究和发现
那我们首先来简单介绍一下
事件驱动的一个编程范式
与面向过程的编程范式的一个区别
在这里我们用最经典的联邦学习算法
Fidget Average为例
在Fidget Average中每一个轮次
然后服务器首先会将全聚模型进行广播
发送给所有的参与的客户端
每个客户端在接到全聚模型之后
会基于自己的本地数据进行训练
然后将自己的模型更新
发送给服务端
服务端在接收到所有的客户端
收过来的模型更新之后
会进行联邦聚合
聚合之后得到了新的全聚模型
然后开启另一个轮次
进行广播以及后续的训练
然后这样一个编程
这样一个算法
如果我们采用面向过程的方式来进行编程
那我们会得到比较自然的
像右边这样一个过程
然后首先
Sever Broadcast Model to Client
然后不同的Client
然后Receive the Model
然后它就会Locally Trin
然后并且Return Model Updates
然后在这之后
如果说Sever Receive the Model Updates
然后之后它就会Perform Aggregation
以及在新的轮子中
Send a Global Model to all the parties
那么如果这样的过程
我们采用
事件驱动的方式来看
它会是这样子的
在事件驱动中
我们并没有这样一个
很完整的流程要求大家写出来
而是大家只需要考虑清楚说
不同的参与方
它在收到
也就是说看到不同的事件的时候
它该进行如何的操作
也就是说我们只需要定义
不同的1万起以及相应的Handle了
就譬如说Effort Arrogate为例
那么对于Client来说
它只有一种Event和Handle的Pay
那就是说
当它收到模型的时候
它需要做的就是
Locally Trend Model and Updates
然后对于Sever来说
它也只有一个是Event和Handle的Pay
那就是说
当它收到足够的Model Updates的时候
它就Perform Aggregation
以及Send a Global Model
去开启下一个轮子
那么只要我们想好
每个参与方
当它遇到不同的1万起的时候
该进行如何的操作
进行Handle
那么整个过程
其实就已经定义清楚了
当然在经典的Fight Arrogate中
对于这两种不同的变成范氏
大家可能觉得
他们没有办法看出它的一个好处
所以我们在Fight Arrogate的基础上
我们来做一个简单的扩展
就譬如说在很多连绑区算法中
在本地训练的过程中
我们都需要Client之间进行一个相互交换
然后譬如说在图链帮学习中
我们需要不同的Client
然后它进行一些中间结果的交换
然后来才能完成本地的训练
当然这样的过程
在其他的课题中都有很多的实践
那么如果说我们采用面向过程的变成范氏
来做这个扩展呢
我们可以看到这些红色的字
就是我们需要增加的带码模块
包括说我们需要定义清楚说
哪些Client然后进行
中间过程的一些交换
然后以及说后续
然后不同的Client来进行
继续进行一些local training以及update
但是如果我们是采用
Event和EventHandler这样一个
事件驱动的变成范氏的话
它的修改其实就会比较清晰一些
我们主要定一个新的Event
也就是说如果不同的Client
它收到intermediate results
就是不同的Client收到来自
其他Client的中间结构的时候
它需要进行如何Handling
以及就是我们对原有的一个Handler function
然后进行一个简单的修改
那么这样子的话
就可以清晰的定义出
我们到底做了哪些修改
然后但是呢
整个其实变成过程
以及以及联邦过程的一个启动
都是没有任何改变的
那么这样其实更容易
让大家能够想清楚
核心的改变在哪里
以及这样的改变的实现
并不会去影响到整个联邦学习过程
所以这样的变成范氏
然后在越来越复杂的联邦学习算法中
是有比较大的优势的
在后续的个性化联邦学习
以及图联邦学习
还有联邦学习的攻击中
大家可以有更好的体会
那么为了实现这样一个变成理念呢
然后我们的联邦学习框架Fidler Scope
也进行了非常多的抽象与设计
然后我们在这里进行一个简单的介绍
然后首先我们将所有的服务端
SoR以及参与方Client
然后都进行那个抽象统一为Walker
然后Walker
然后他的一个定义
事实上是通过Ewant和Handler
这样一个Pass来进行定义的
也就是说每个Walker
他是通过他对不同的事件
如何进行处理
然后来定义自己的一个行为的
然后SoR和Client
他可能拥有自己的数据以及模型
然后在训练过程中
然后SoR和Client
以及Client和Client之间
都需要进行一些信息交换
那么就说Client的最重要的行为
就说他需要进行一个Local Training
所以说他有一个China这样一个部件
然后SoR
然后也就是服务器端
他最重要的功能是进行联邦聚合
所以他有一个Aggregate
但是在这里我们的设计中
我们尽量将Aggregate以及China
然后和联邦行为进行那个结合
也就是说
大家譬如说在考虑Client
他做的China的时候
其实无需要考虑说在联邦学
以及非联邦学下有什么区别
他事实上就是说
因为联邦学的行为
已经被其他的部件定义了
China就是一个比较独立的
结偶后的一个部件
所以他可以做到说在联邦学习中的China
和在非联邦学中的China
其实可以是非常类似
或者甚至是完全一样的
然后以及有一个Monitor的模块
然后来对联邦学习的训练过程
以及包括结果进行各种的监管和可视化
然后刚才提到就是说
不同的Walker
也就是说Client于SoR
以及Client和Client之间
然后大家都会有各种各样的通信
那么通信的所有的细节
都被封装在了Communicator这样一个模块中
然后包括就是说
大家在进行一些单击访证Standalone的时候
包括以及真的有很多不同的系统
或者我们可以做到真实部署的时候
然后这两种模式在我们这里
都进行了统一
大家也可以比较容易的将Standalone
开发的一些东西
直接在Disputed模式下进行一个部署
因为这样他们的接口都是统一的
然后最重要的就是Communicator这个里面
然后我们将所有的信息统一成了Message
然后Message
然后它可以有它的不同的Pipe
然后当然最重要的就是说
它收到Message的时候
然后如何进行一个不同的Tool
也就是Handle Function
那么介绍完Finderscope的设计之后
我们来基于Finderscope这样一个经验的算法
我们来看看
我们在Finderscope中如何动手去实现它
然后我们刚才说过
在Finderscope的设计中
然后客户端以及服务端
不同的这样一个参与方
事实上它是都被抽象成了Walker
以及它的定义是通过事件和处理函数
也就是Event Handle这样一个Pire来定义的
那么首先我们来看
我们如何定义客户端
然后客户端的行为
其实就是说当它收到拳击模型的时候
然后它需要进行一个本地的训练
并且将模型进行更新
我们通过这个代码片段定好之后
客户端的行为其实就已经定义清楚了
然后接着我们定义服务端
服务端就是说
联邦聚合的条件被满足的时候
它就进行聚合以及开启新的一个轮子
然后定义了客户端以及服务端之后
那么我们刚才提到就是说
客户端它有China
然后服务端它有Aggregator
然后当然我们刚才也提到就是说
他们的一个特点就是已经被解诱了
然后大家无需考虑说
在联邦学习的场景下
China该如何实现
事实上它的一个实验方式
在Finderscope中
大家可以直接附用
然后在非联邦学习中的实验方式
然后那么定义好这些之后
我们就可以很方便的
构建出整个联邦学习的任务
然后为了进一步的方便大家去使用
Finderscope也是提供了
非常多现有的联邦学习算法
然后用户可以通过简单的配置文件
就能够直接调用
以及来进行更多的动手实验
比如说第一步
然后我们可能需要准备数据
在这里Finderscope也有了非常多
给大家准备好的公开数据集
大家可以通过简单的一个配置文件
然后就进行使用
当我们也支持大家使用自己的数据集
进行一个定制
在准备好数据之后
那么第二步就是在配置文件里面
准备模型
然后这个模型主要是说
就是对于Client来说
大家需要使用什么样的China
然后也当也包括
就是说选择一些联邦聚合的方法
以及联邦的算法等等
当然在这里我们主要是配置China的模型
然后在这里也是
Finderscope提供了很多
大家常用的时间网络架构
然后当然我们也支持
可以把自己的
就是用户自己的模型
然后定制注册进去
然后第三步就是说
配置好数据配置好算法之后
然后其他的就是剩下的一些
其他的相关的一些配置
就包括像就是优化器的配置
然后以及就是说
包括Loss以及其他一些细节的配置
然后所有的这些配置信息写好之后
那大家就可以很快的
开启大家的联邦学习之旅了
接下来我们进行
本门课程的第三部分的介绍
在这个部分里
然后我们希望能够给大家介绍一些
目前比较热门
或者说比较promising的研究方向
能够帮助大家顺利开启
大家的联邦学习研究之路
首先第一个topic是图联邦学习
然后federator graph learning
那首先来说我们为什么要介绍
这样一个topic呢
首先其实图数据
然后作为一种非常普遍的数据
它存在于非常非常多的
不同的应用以及场景中
譬如说在医院和医院之间的
医疗保健的合作方面
或者包括在银行和银行的
繁细前合作方面
以及包括很多推荐系统
可以被formalize成一个图的问题
包括现在比较流行的
aifosense这样一个topic下面
然后所有在这些场景中
我们处理到的数据
它都是图graph
然后图联邦相比于
其他的联邦学习呢
其实有一个比较大的区别
就是说在这样的link
或者node来我的图联邦学习下
然后大家除掉在
其他普通的联邦学习之下
考虑那些问题
我们还需要考虑说
如何能以一种privacy preservation的方式
然后促进不同图之间的一个信息交换
因为我们可以在医疗保健
和繁协前的例子中
可以更明显的看到
就每一个client它有的
其实是一个supergraph的一个part
也就是一个subgraph
然后subgraph和subgraph之间
他们存在着很多信息的缺失
我们需要通过一种隐私保护的机制
然后就安全的推测
这些缺失的信息
来提升图联邦学习的任务
这也是我们认为
图联邦区别于
其他联邦的一个比较大的区别
以及一个很比较大的一个挑战
那么为了帮助图联邦学习
这样一个subtopic的一个推进
然后我们打磨院这边
然后有一个
专门设计的
Farted Scope GNN一个package
然后我们简称FSG
然后因为这个工作
就是做的比较扎实
并且推动
确实希望之后
能够推动图联邦的一个发展
所以说我们这个工作也被
KDD2022官方授予了最佳论文讲
然后在这个FSG这个package中
我们主要有四个部分
第一个部分就是说
我们准备了很多数据级
就是data zoo
因为就是说图联邦
因为目前还比较
处在一个研究的初期
所以说数据级
还没有得到一个很好的统一
或者一个比较清晰的一个分类
所以我们在这里
我们针对不同级别的任务
然后并且考虑就说
数据的NANDID现象
然后我们对所有的数据级
进行一个比较好的一个
划分和准备
然后第二个部分就是说
GNN模型级
就是之前我们提到的
就是每个客户端
Trinna的一个部分
然后在这里
我们也是集成了
非常多的GNN模型
方便大家使用
并且我们也是
支持每个客户端
进行一个个性化的
联邦学习架构设计
审议网络架构设计
然后第三个就是说
图联邦算法
然后目前我们在
Algomzu这个部件里
然后也是集合了
包括最新的像
FatSagePlus
然后等等这些
最新提出的图联邦算法
此外我们也是为了
帮助大家能够更好的建立
图联邦学习的基准
所以我们有非常多的一个
通过配置文件就可以准确的
复线很多基准结果
然后此外
就说我们的FSG
也是有非常好的
扩展性
因为我们在数据级这边
我们提供了很多
很好用的splitter
然后可以方便大家
进行对图
进行一些切分或者模拟
然后在GNNModel这一块
我们也是提供了注册机制
可以让大家可以
除了使用我们
提供的内置的
GNN模型
大家可以很方便的
进行一个注册
然后以及在
图联邦算法这方面
然后因为我们之前
提到过有用
整个Fiderscope用了
实践驱动的方式
所以它能够很好的支持
图联邦里面
各种意志信息的交换
然后并且很好的
支持这些丰富的行为
然后最后一个方面
就是说在扩展性方面
然后我们也是对
图联邦算法
我们可以结合很多
包括像个性化算法
包括之前提到的差分隐私
包括之后提到的
攻击算法等等
可以让大家对
图联邦学习的研究
更加全面一些
在这里
然后我们
因为之前我们讲到了
就说我们整个
Fiderscope
然后实践驱动的一个设计
在这里我们也是
为了让大家更好的理解
我们展示了在FSCG中
我们如何去用
实践驱动的方式
然后去更好的
更加减别的
去实现FSCG Plus这样一个算法
对于未来
就是图联邦学习的一个发展
在这里我们提供一些
我们自己的一些看法
就是说
第一个我们觉得
比较重要的问题
就刚才提到的
就是说
因为在图联邦里面
每个Client
有的是一个纸图
那么如何在这种情况下
以更加安全的方式
每个Client
能够从其他Client的纸图中
借用或者推断
推断一些信息
来提升
所学的任务呢
然后第二个
我们觉得很有趣的方向
就是说
在FL设定下的
字件读学习
至于提这个任务是因为
就是说
联邦学习本身
就有比较严重的
non-ID现象
在图联邦这个设定下
然后
它会更加严重一些
那么字件读学习
可能是我们认为
比较看好的一种解决方案
然后
第三个
比较好的研究方向
可能是
因为现在就说
我们已经用
就是
很多机构都在研究
用Machine的方式
然后来助力
AFO Science这样一个topic
那么就是说
在很多机构
都在做的分子属性
预测这样一个任务上
然后因为不同的机构
大家有的分子
或者甚至他们的
标签都是私有的
那么这个时候
该怎么更好地去做
联邦学习
来解决这些问题
这也是一个
非常值得研究的问题
上面是关于图联邦学习
这样一个topic
然后接下来
我们介绍
第二个topic
叫个性化联邦学习
那么首先来说
就是说
我们为什么需要
个性化的联邦学习呢
然后在这里
我们就是说
讲述几个原因
第一个原因
就是说
刚才提到的数据
囊ID分布
就是意志数据的
一个问题
然后因为事实上
因为
就是说每个
尤其在class device的场景下
然后数据的产生
以及它的收集等等
由于各种各样的条件限制
或者说本来数据
可能就是很
就是它的generation distribution
就是非常不一样的
所以会导致
每个数据端
它用的数据都是分布
非常的意志
然后所以整体看起来
然后囊ID现象
是非常严重的
然后第二个
就是说
每个客户端
大家拥有的资源
是不一样的
就包括像
计算能力
以及就是说在联邦学习
尤其是class device的场景下
我们非常需要
考虑的通信能力
还有就是说
大家每个中端
大家的存储能力等等
这些系统之间
存在着
非常大的差异化
那么就说
如果我们不考虑
个性化联邦学习的话
那么就说
很多本地信息
就难以进行一个融合
同时呢
就说
我们存在一个
向下兼容的问题
就是譬如说
于某一个client
然后它的
譬如说它的内存
或者磁盘特别小
导致说
它只能容忍一个
比较小的模型
那么如果我们
不采用个性化联邦学习的话
那么大家就需要
所有的联邦学习参与者
都向下兼容
然后来做到
同样一个模型
被不同的client采用
那么如果是这样子的话
这样就会造成
就说
对于很多联邦参与者来说
大家的性能不是最优的
以及会造成很多
其他包括像
NARID现象会造成
拳击模型无法收敛
或者收敛比较慢
或者不同的client
会产生很多不公平的现象
那么为了解决
这些意志性带来的挑战
然后就有了
个性化联邦学习
然后在这里
我们对
就是个性化联邦学习
现有的算法
然后做了一个简单的分类
然后我们可以从
就是说
是哪部分行为
被个性化
是client的行为
还是说soul的行为
也就是说
每个
比如说client side
然后它的个性化
可以从不同的几个方面
来进行一些分类
就比如说包括
每client
可以对自己的
有用的模型
进行个性化的限制
就是regardation
或者说
我们可以通过
就说
整体联邦学习来说
大家有不止一个的
权力模型
也就是model mixture
然后等等方案
来实现
就是说client side
的一个个性化
对于soul side
然后我们可以通过
比如说像multi task
能力
或者说对于
参与的设备方
也就是参与
client这边
然后我们进行一个
有偏的bias的一个sample
来实现
个性化一些行为
然后为了帮助
大家能够更好的
就是进入
个性化联邦学习
这样一个topic
然后我们是对
这个方向
进行了一个
建立了一个benchmark
然后在这个benchmark
中
然后我们实现了
现有的
二十多个非常
就是实状的一个
baseline
然后方便大家使用
然后数据级方面
然后也是我们
提供了非常丰富的
就包括
像cowl 像图像
然后包括文本
然后推荐
然后以及语音
这些方向
然后以及就是
评测
就是为了方便大家
能够更好的使用
这些baseline
以及这些数据
然后我们也是
就像在实战
部分提到的
我们这边也是有
就是通过一些
配置文件
让大家可以得到
非常丰富的结果
就包括
如果大家想关注
泛化性能
或者说公平性性能
或者是想去
研究一些
系统方面的
一些优化
那这里有非常
丰富的指标
大家可以非常容易的拿到
对于就是
个性化联邦学习
我们在这里也讲几个
我们认为
可能比较好的一些
研究方向
就包括说
第一个就是说
虽然现在
就是说
个性化联邦学习
大家有比较好的
就是说
introclient的一个泛化
但是对于
unseen的client
然后表现
依然是比较差的
这也要求
就是说
有更好的泛化能力
然后
第二个就是说
目前还是
就是许多PFL方法
然后他并不是很乳棒
第三个就是说
对于特定的领域
然后PFL的研究
仍是处在初期的
就譬如说
对于graph data
譬如说对于
nlp领域的一些
个性化联邦
也还是
目前还有很多的机会
然后最后一点是
我们觉得就是说
PFL就是
虽然说
现有的方法有很多
在算法方面的一些
非常好的设计
但是对于计算量
然后对于通信
等等这些系统的开销
因为他们在实际上
有更大的影响
所以说我们觉得
这个也是一个
非常好的方向
去优化这些指标
然后为了方便大家
去研究这些问题
然后我们提供的
PFL Bunch
也是非常容易去扩展的
然后包括
就像之前
在实践里提到的春
然后它已经几号
然后大家可以去
更好的去
丰富这个春了
然后包括对于
大家做研究的话
需要进行访真
那么在这里
我们也是支持
很多意志设备资源的访真
以及包括
对于Privacy要求
对于security
就是安全部分等等
然后我们后续
会提到的
Attack这个模块
大家可以相互配合
然后开展一个
交叉的研究
好 上面这是
个性化联邦学习
这样一个
比较热门的一个
研究课题
然后第三个
我们想讲的方向是
联邦超参优化
也就是Fight HPO
然后首先讲一下
什么是HPO
就是其实大家在使用
比如说尤其是
深度学习模型的时候
我们其实需要对很多
超参数进行一个
Tune去调节
然后以达到
就是说
模型的Performance
会能够有一个
比较好的一个表现
但是呢
就是事实上
我们可以把这个
调参的过程
当作是一个优化问题
但是这个优化问题
是非常难的
因为就是说
首先它的搜索空间
可能是离散的
当然也可能是连续的
但是在这个搜索空间上
然后它的评估函数
也就是说
我们想去优化
整个背后的这个方式
它可能是没有解析
形式
并且是不光滑的
所以这个给超参优化
带来很多挑战
当然超
就是说HPU这个方向
也是有非常多
比较深厚的一些研究
那么就是说
在联邦这个设定下
然后HPU会有一些新的挑战呢
就最直接的一个
就是也是机遇
也是挑战的
就是说在HPU下面
然后我们会有更多的
Fidelity的这样一个
保证度的问题
那为什么要谈保证度呢
就是说我们刚才提到
就是说我们可以把
超参优化当作是一个
HPU当作是一个优化的问题
但是如果我们需要去
精确的评估这个函数呢
其实代价非常大
那么就需要
能不能以一种廉价的方式
或者说降低这个评估的代价
那么就是Multimodality
Multifidelity的一个想法就了
就是譬如说
我们可以减少它训练的轮数
或者说在评估
某个函数的时候
我们只考虑训练起的
一个sub-sample的一个词集
然后又通过这样的方式
然后来平衡精确度
和一个效率的问题
那么在超参优化
这个研究topic
然后在联邦设定下
就会有
因为我们联邦学习
会引入新的一些超参
它就会有新的定义域
然后包括还有就是说
因为我们这里有很多Client
然后每个Client有自己的数据
然后所以说
这里还涉及到
就是说如何去并行的
然后可以更加便捷的去探索
整个超参优化的一个空间
然后为了帮助大家
能够快速的开启
在联邦超参优化这样一个问题
我们也是
帮大家建立了FindHPO
这样一个benchmark
然后譬如说在这里
我们对于整个
就是说对于很多任务
我们建立了它的一个
直接把这个
大家需要去
去evaluate
这些信息都已经给
以不同的形式存了下来
就包括大家可以通过
绕model去access这些数据
或者说通过tabloid
这样一个model去access
或者我们也有比较好的
通过srogate这样一个model
然后去可以做一些估计
然后在这里就像
在pfl里面一样
我们这里也是
我们提供的数据节
然后看过了包括像
cvnlp
然后tabloid
tabloid data
以及graph data
然后面对很多
不管是传统的HPO方法
还是对于联邦下的
新的HPO方法
都有了很多评估
然后这些结果
方便大家去进行进步的探索
就譬如说
是不是多保证度的方法
然后会更加
更加好一些
以及FindHPO
如何通过并行探索
去获得更大的收益等等
这些问题都是很值得去进一步探索
那么最后
我们再来讲一下
就是第四个研究的方向
就是联邦学习中的隐私攻击
事实上联邦学习中的
不管是安全还是隐私的威胁
其实非常多
然后但是
在这里我们着重讲
对于隐私的攻击
那么在联邦学习中
隐私的攻击是指说
我们通过在联邦学习的
学习过程中
然后利用学习过程中的信息
去推断出某一个特定Plant
然后它的敏感信息
就是它的隐私数据
然后之所以研究隐私攻击
就说它是一种
其实对于联邦学习来说
隐私攻击是一种非常有效
并且直观的方式
我们来看看说
我们的一连邦学习设计的算法
是不是能够提供
比较强的保护
当然还有其他很多攻击
但是有些攻击
不一定是针对联邦学习的
那么对于联邦学习的隐私攻击
按照它的目标来分
我们可以分为四个大类
一个叫Membership Influence Attack
一个是Property Influence
还有Class Representative Attack
还有就是Training Data
或者Label Influence
然后第一类攻击
就是我们需要想知道
说到底某一条数据
是不是存在于某一个Client那种
然后第二个就是说
我们想通过联邦学习任务
去推测一些关于
每个Client它隐私数据的
一些其他的Property
然后第三类攻击是说
对于有的Client来说
因为大家的数据都只是一个
整体数据的subside
所以有的客户端
可能本身就天然的缺少某些类
他就希望就是说
通过联邦学习过程的信息
然后去推测出
就是说对于某些他缺失的类的
代表性数据长什么样子
然后最后一个就是说
比较直接的就是说
直接通过联邦学习中的信息
然后来推测某一个Client
它的Train Data是什么
或者说某一个Train Data
它的Label是什么
然后为了帮助大家能够
快速地开展联邦学习中
隐私攻击的这个研究
然后我们也是已经在factor scope中
集成了非常多的不同的攻击算法
对于刚才提到的四个大类
我们都有把典型的算法
进行一个复线以及内置
然后大家可以非常方便地使用
那么就说说完了攻击
大家可能会非常关注
就是说那么我们如何
做防御呢
就是说defence
因为如果没有defence的话
那这个就是我们使用的
联邦学习算法
在隐私方面
就会比较脆弱
那防御方法其实也有很多
就包括我们一开始提到的
就是说联邦学习
需要去和MPC
或者说DP以及HE
进行一个联动
然后大家在联邦学习算法中
然后也使用
包括像MPCH和DP
然后来进一步加强
隐私的一个保护
可是还有一些
就比如说针对image data的话
然后我们可以
是可以使用一些像mix up
或者说mix up的一个扩展
然后去提供更多的一些
类似于弱加密的一个保护
当然这些算法
我们很快会在
Finderscope中提供给大家
从使用的角度来说
其实如果要防御
目前的隐私攻击
然后依据就是nips21的
这一篇工作来说
其实有很多
实际上比较
practical的一个建议
就比如说
我们尽量使用
比较大的batter size
然后以及就是说
联合使用包括像
联邦区以及其他
隐私保护技术
可能这些都是能够有效的
底防各种攻击的
然后除了隐私攻击之外
然后还有一个大类
是投毒攻击
就是pawning attack
然后包括像
对data的pawning
或者对model的pawning等等
然后这些算法
我们也是很快
会在联邦
学习框架Finderscope中
然后进行一个内置
然后很快的
可以提供给大家进行使用
以及进行后续的研究
那么到这里
我们也在第三部分中介绍了
四个比较热门的
研究方向给大家
希望大家能够
基于这些信息
然后能够快速开启
自己的联邦学习之旅
然后最后小小的
打一个广告
这是我们Finderscope
目前的团队
我们也得到了
达沐院这边
非常多的支持
然后可以去做这样一个
比较优秀的框架
提供给大家
如果说大家有任何问题
或者希望通过实习
或者正式员工的方式
加入我们
也感谢大家随时来联系我
谢谢大家的联听